the gyro can experience wondering why
other people's success or wondering why
other people are successful is their
refuge of losers yes it's a loser
mentality it's a loser occupation it's a
it's a it's a loser practice because
you're wondering why other people are
successful like who gives a [ __ ]
you can say you think it sucks but to
spend time wondering why someone is
successful and hating on some other than
successful it doesn't do any good it's
like what is that old expression that
jealousy is it's a poison that does the
opposite of its intended doesn't affect
the other person at all but it poisons
yourself yeah it wastes your your energy
and time and it just is so it's so
indicative that you are insecure yes
it's like people don't realize how what
a giveaway that is when they are talking
[ __ ] you're just like oh this is just
showing me that you [ __ ] don't like
yourself well I figured out there's
something that I figured out personally
and that I try to relay this and I try
to be more clear and more concise the
way a relay it the way I look at that is
that your mind you have a certain amount
of bandwidth this is why I don't read
Instagram comments or Twitter comments
or YouTube comments like I don't mean
time if I read them it's an accident but
to seek them out know like you have
bandwidth I don't spend time wondering
why I hate things or hating things or
hating on someone or being jealous you
have let's say let's call it units you
have a hundred units of bandwidth in
your mind so that means there's a
hundred units so you can spend on things
you care about or you could let your
mind be occupied why some stupid [ __ ]
Twitter feud that you're in with some
idiot you don't even know and you could
spend 30 percent of your Twitter ban
well your your your mind bandwidth on
this and then you only have 70% for the
things you love and then maybe you're
involved in some [ __ ] relationship
but someone who's an idiot and you're
arguing back and forth with them well
there is another 30% that's gone now you
got you have 40% left you have 40% for
the things you love instead of a hundred
percent but if you only concentrate on
the things you care about that means
something to you and learn how to do
that like you were talking about
meditation yeah it's a form of
meditation yep because you're learning
how to avoid the little road bumps in
the ditches on the side of the road it
could suck your bandwidth your bandwidth
give them just a little bit and go okay
no no no but or you could lean in like
how you saying when you stop drinking
all of a sudden your career took off you
started doing well because man let's get
more bandwidth and you know less
problems
yeah problem that you had that was
rotting you away no longer existed so
now sudden it frees up your time and you
realize oh my god there's so many funny
things that I could talk about and I
have so much energy and I'm so healthy I
could just go onstage and have fun and
then you're killing it when was the last
thing that you go no no got it like you
maybe gave it a little too much
bandwidth do you still struggle with
those things no I don't and not really
anymore but it's been a gradual process
like a member of the first I do have
been a jealous dude in stand-up like
when you first started out you had to
have hated the guy that was getting
ahead like right I don't know any male
comic was the beginning yeah yeah what
happened to that you get successful in a
development like before I was successful
before I was successful I realized it
was stupid
long before because when I was like an
amateur I would see guys that were
killing and and I'd be like [ __ ] him
like why is he doing good like that guy
sucks and this guy sucks and you know
how come he got this and he got that and
then I remember thinking like this is a
gigantic waste of time and I got into
comedy because I'm a fan of comedy and
my concentrating on people that suck are
being jealous about people that are
doing well does me is zero good but
instead if someone does well I can be
inspired and I can get fired up by it I
mean I figured this out in my early 20s
I was like okay this is a yeah I have a
poor way of looking at it because it's a
martial arts thing because in martial
arts like you can't be jealous of
someone else's ability you have to
realize you might have to fight them
someday
so by realizing that they're really good
you you were forced to be objective
about it and you have to go to work like
you have to go [ __ ] that guy's better
than me I got to get better and you have
to go to work right there's no there's
no positive
benefit in under estimating someone
under estimating someone will get you
[ __ ] killed like literally yeah yeah
ash in smashed in your face like you
don't want it convincing yourself that
the things that you're jealous of them
for aren't really that's good get your
that will get you killed
so you that's right that's it dude
that's totally it because the things
that I get jealous of or have and I'm
better about it now than I've ever been
but you know you see other women I mean
my jealousies are always with other
women yeah it's just the way it is and I
have to fight it and I'm really good
about it now to be like actually
inspired by women who are funnier than
me but that's awesome but and to use it
to be like okay then I need to be better
I need to get up to that level not just
I need to go home and write it like
fires me up as opposed to like why and
it's powerful for everybody it's
powerful for them it's powerful for you
yes it's like there's no negative aspect
to it it's like you should be thankful
that there's women out there that make
you feel uncomfortable yet like when I
see someone just murder on stage [ __ ] I
want to go to work yeah right I want to
get home and right yeah I want to I want
to go perform I'm like [ __ ] that guy
just killed her holy [ __ ] she just
crushed she's out there killing it he's
doing so good
it makes me want to work harder and in
that sense find someone's not doing
anything bad as long as someone's not
victimizing someone what they're doing
is they're there they're there showing
you that it's possible to do better than
you're doing yeah
and that's good
[Applause]